here's the story it's a little past 10 p.m
right now and I was editing a movie reaction
for a couple I was a couple hours into the
edit and then um something went wrong with
my computer and then I lost all the progress
on that edit and I went
screw this
I'm gonna watch the whale I've been on the
to-do list I was like sure why not it seems
like a good time I've never seen the trailer
for this movie I've heard great things about
it specifically that bread and Fraser is awesome
in it and I love Darren aronofsky's work I
know they can be quite sad and intense I'm
not sure exactly what the movie's gonna fully
uh entail or or be about uh but the subject
matter does sound intriguing to me at least
from the few things I've heard about it I've
told you guys have been here as part of the
reject Nation for a while yeah I've been in
therapy for like a decade at this point and
you know a big part of a lot of my therapy
discussions has has definitely been my struggles
with body dysmorphia I had it since I was
a little kid binge eating and using food as
a coping mechanism I've had some massive Kuwait
gains and weight losses over the years it's
a constant struggle every time I'm on camera
it's the first thing I'm always thinking about
myself as much stomach even when I got stressed
by that I instantly get this urge to be like
I'm gonna go get Taco Bell or something like
that while I know this movie is not going
to be any anything like that at least I imagine
won't be necessarily about that that was part
of the Intriguing part of the subject matter
of oh yeah a guy who uh uses like pretty much
harms himself with overeating and I can relate
to that to a certain extent definitely not
the degree of the makeup effects that I've
seen applied to burn and Frazier but there's
a part of me that melee was like yeah I feel
like I could understand a decent amount of
that subject at least regardless you're gonna
throw that all out the window throw my personal
life out the window and just watch this movie
so with that in mind Let's Escape leave a
like uh subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when we got a reaction
up on this channel that might pique your interest
full interaction watch long so you sync up
with your own copy of the whale I bought this
off Amazon just now available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you to everyone
who's become a super sexy reject since sincerely
your support has been exceptional without
further ado let's see what all the hype is
about
[Music]
interesting is it in this aspect ratio the
whole movie it'd be good for everyone to review
the paragraph structure PDF I sent you a few
weeks ago he's not on screen and yes the camera
on my laptop still doesn't work believe me
you're not missing much oh
this title has always fascinated me
oh
geez just use your key gosh are you okay should
I come on maybe that's actually calling in
that's embarrassing do you have a phone at
my phone's dead I need to just read it okay
that the author is just trying to save us
from his own sad story this book made me think
about my own life and then it made me feel
glad so he's the whale and the makeup is incredible
it's an essay but why did you have me read
it to you because I thought I was dying and
I wanted to hear it one last time this is
Adara daronovsky movie he's probably going
to die shut up
what hush you probably have really high blood
pressure man deep breath
he's got such a sincerity to his performances
man what was my blood pressure 238 over 134.
wow we that's you must be from New Life why
the hell would you want to believe that the
world is about to end I believe that when
Christ returns it's going to be beautiful
yes believe me he doesn't want to hear about
new life because it's caused him a lot of
pain oh this guy's just gonna stick around
isn't he killed his boyfriend killed his boyfriend
what he probably won't be here next week where
is he going I'm sorry put it together man
you have congestive heart failure if you don't
go to the hospital you'll be dead by the weekend
you will die sounds like that's what he wants
well then I better get to work because I have
a lot of essays this week God damn it I'm
sorry did you still want to hear about Christ
message of love and Savage no he does not
God I still don't understand why you had me
read that essay to you this is a really good
essay it's it's really this has to be based
on a play yeah it has a has a real Play Rhythm
I'm sorry you say you're sorry one more time
I will shove a knife right into you I swear
to God go ahead What's it gonna do my internal
organs are two feet in at least
[Laughter] I have a good morbid sense of humor
please
that's sad swatching your friend die thank
you
oh man
that is [__] sad later they set out on
a ship captain by the pirate named his entire
life set grounds trying to kill a certain
whale we think this is sad because whale doesn't
have any emotions wow it won't help him at
all this book made me think about my own life
is ultimately the whale but he's also the
other characters
counting this week I wonder why the choice
to shoot it in this aspect ratio
how long this is gonna last
thank you God this level of self-harm
does this mean I'm gonna get fat so that's
cool you're a senior right you actually care
of course they care so there is sweating his
ass off I just thought that maybe we could
spend some time with each other time with
you
this is a terrible week you'd still be that
piece of [__] dad who walked out of me
when I was eight all because he wanted one
of his students can I have one of these
yet she's here just thought that maybe we
can get to know each other
I don't even know I'm here oh he invited her
directly I can pay you I can pay you how much
can you pay me everything I have 120 000 something
like that I'd have to check don't tell your
mom
stand up and walk over to me I can't really
shut up come over here she is a commanding
presence
yes oh God
oh uh shuts that door doesn't even want to
give herself a second to feel sorry for him
[Music] yeah everyone just wants to check
up on him it measures perspiration it's an
indicator of stress here I don't need a little
machine to tell me to take a few deep breaths
and stop sweating and sometimes you do though
was she here
you haven't seen her since she was eight years
old and you're gonna reconnect with her by
doing her homework for her it's fine it's
not fine you're gonna help it is stress level
it doesn't look like she has any friends
I'm worried that she's forgotten what an amazing
person she is fall okay I have to go soon
trying to help but also enable very interesting
nice to go puke was brighter book oh oh my
God are you choking
[Music] oh [__]
okay damn this guy could die at any moment
seems like a guy who's made a lot of mistakes
in his life but it's probably a decent guy
underneath all of it it's a really depressed
one if you say that Walt Whitman wrote song
for myself yeah it's called A Song of Myself
my title is better it's overwritten and dumb
and repetitive and and in reality he's just
some worthless 19th century ouch that's an
interesting perspective it would make for
an interesting essay nah man you can't be
honest something with your harder than a homophobia
part is your mother with anyone right now
no why are you interested
of course not I love their scene work together
man they're so good together why'd you get
all that weight I don't if you're gonna interrogate
me I'm going to do the same thing oh it's
like he did he do it intentionally someone
close to me passed away and it it had an effect
you had him over for dinner once when Mom
was in Montana visiting Grandma uh damn how'd
he die I don't I I really don't want to talk
about that right now
tell me what you really think you want me
to write what I really think I'll be right
back in like 20 minutes [Applause]
man the talking pool of Sadie sings performance
here it's got a lot of depth underneath those
eyes kind of actor you could feel what she's
thinking and Brendan Fraser is okay now he's
phenomenal I get all the hype
foreign
asked about the boyfriend you okay yeah yeah
fine I'm fine
who's outside are you his friends or his daughter
are you surprised yeah I guess what's more
surprising that a gay guy has a daughter that
someone actually found this
song from New Life what I like about religion
is that it assumes that everyone is an idiot
and that they're all incapable of saving themselves
I think they've got something right with that
you could write an essay I have some pamphlets
that I think how did you just do that are
you coming back tomorrow I'm sorry what's
happening yeah what what are you doing I'm
really uncertain about that whole dynamic
there I have probably read everything new
life church has ever written that's great
and everything but these tracks are just the
beginning there's so much more in the Bible
that we can't I read the Bible [Laughter]
God creates us expels us from Paradise we
wander around for thousands of years killing
each other before he comes back and saves
144 000 of us meanwhile seven and a half billion
of us fall into hell foreign yeah that is
perspective there's a reason why I knocked
on your door right when you needed someone
the most isn't there any way I can help I
mean it seems like he needs someone the most
all the time well there's something you could
do for me I hope you know I wasn't I'm not
oh my God I'm pleased you gotta believe me
when I say I'm not attracted to you you're
a fetus please just let me help
thank you it's very helpful praise be to God
it's a fat guy wheelchair what would you pay
for this thing nothing we ordered it for a
patient a few months ago what happened
they lost a lot of weight
good actually this is really nice yeah it's
great for him she got an electric where are
you from uh Iowa you're from Iowa and you
came to Idaho to do missionary work he's dying
he's refusing to go to the hospital but he
needs is spiritual guidance foreign
slide over my big brother did some missionary
work for New Life went to South America dad
had set it all up pushed them into getting
married to the skull from the church he barely
knew practically arranged he met someone else
fell in love started a whole new life I thought
he was going to be able to get over all that
religious stuff but it was like a cancer he
couldn't shake it it's a knee deep in you
man stop sleeping stopped eating lost a ton
of weight this guy's out jogging on a bike
path here the river in Lewiston sees something
washed up on shore and that was Alan the love
of Charlie's life and my brother oh to this
day my dad won't admit it denying him to the
end damn in a few days he's probably gonna
be dead so what he needs is for you to leave
him alone I'm the only one who can help him
you understand me wow he managed to sneak
up on their conversation actually I got another
night shift tonight I better uh you good for
the night
damn bonded by the trauma I mean they're probably
bonded before that but Alan's death just unified
them even more
yeah you can um
[Music] Charlie have a good night okay just
leave the [__] Pizza
his apartment smells this notebook is recorded
I hate everyone
#mood this uh Park and smells this notebook
is [__] I hate everyone
that the author was just trying to save us
from his own sad story foreign
I hate everyone
forget about the poem write whatever you want
whatever you're thinking he's such a sweet
guy you know I was in a really strange place
in my life when I married your mom ask I understand
that you're angry she's hurt okay you know
what you can't throw me away like I'm a piece
of garbage and then suddenly just want to
be my dad eight years later
I'm glad because you taught me something very
important people are [__] seems like they
probably had a really great relationship prior
to all that if you had all that money saved
up and wanted to be a part of my life so bad
you could have been sending money to Mom I
did
it could have been a part of my life
really
who would want me to be a part of their life
foreign
acceptance and resolve I hope you know what
an amazing person you are I couldn't ask for
a more incredible daughter
she has no idea he's died does she
is such an interesting history with all the
characters here
someone's outside again I like this inclusion
I always show the shot of someone walking
around in the back is he okay I don't know
I ground up some Ambien and I put it in a
sandwich where did you get Ambien it's the
pharmacist nice does this make you nervous
because it's just bought I know what pot is
okay no you only think you know what pot is
because your parents told you a bunch of lies
about it don't i've smoked pot before oh oh
I'm so impressed I wasn't trying to impress
you've not smoked pot before yes I have it
it was awesome it was kind of a problem that
is the stupidest thing I've ever heard in
my entire life I had a problem you were a
stoner you had a hobby all right I'm gonna
go just tell him I was here you know you leave
I'll feed him the rest of the pills I have
in the bottle what wow it's like a devil and
angel in this room ticket I don't want if
you don't take a hit I'm gonna call the police
and I'm gonna tell them that you tried to
take a hit damn girl you are you are something
you're for God
what are you gonna do with that picture I'm
gonna Master to it look I'm just [__]
with you all right damn you're a Ted's personality
can I take another hit it goes against a religion
and that makes you hypocrite go ahead they're
all Hypocrites it's part of being a sinner
a human do you find me attractive because
I'm not attracted to you at all just so you
know damn I just don't think you're very good
looking or interesting or intelligence very
mean is this your way of flirting you're not
from your life there's a kid in the grade
below me who goes there he told me that they
stopped doing door-to-door stuff last year
why what is that going on what a random plot
turn Sky Jerry all he had us doing was standing
on corners and handing out pamphlets you could
just tell it you didn't need to earn or prove
his faith at all yeah okay after a while I
was just like am I really helping maybe if
you get Light One Candle I was worried I was
gonna get arrested for smoking pot for stealing
from the mission badass and when everyone
went to sleep I I took the petty cash how
much a hundred twenty thousand dollars two
thousand four hundred and thirty six dollars
I thought I could use this money for my own
mission you know see my faith save just one
person so why do you keep coming back here
hoping to get money from Charlie so that's
why you want to save my job
uh oh Ellie how much money did he offer you
how'd she what you think I'm an idiot you
think I would believe that you were coming
over here out of the kindness of your heart
Charlie doesn't have any money
if you call the money from his teaching it's
been going we could have gotten you anything
you needed last winter when my pickup broke
down and I had to walk through the snow to
get your groceries for you I offered to get
your truck fixed yeah and I refused because
I thought you had seven hundred dollars in
your bank if there was ever any kind of emergency
I'm with money would you I offer to fix the
truck I I don't care about you get that through
your [__] skull
damn this is mean Ellie your your essay
it's
good essay oh Jesus Christ try to make a stir-fry
thing yeah almost at the entire apartment
building on fire
oh my God this looks so painful it was left
raising our kids
for a man what about us for a while you know
you know gosh she's awful isn't she is that
why you kept her for me all this time you
thought that I would think that you're a bad
mother kinda makes you Charlie she's evil
she's not evil
oh what there'll be a grease fire in hell
when he starts to burn
oh that is messed up she's a strong writer
that's your response the only reason you married
me in the first place was to have a kid I
know that very pleased wow this is very unpleasant
I never got to say that I was sorry about
your friend boyfriend
you're wheezing gotten worse should I call
someone probably feels like he destroys the
lives of everyone he loves
we took that trip to the Oregon coast together
I went swimming in the ocean that was the
last time I ever went swimming actually hear
the ocean waves
interesting choice to cut back to this dance
I think you said for days after that it's
about like sea water
dying Mary
I need to know it's just gonna have a decent
life and she's gonna be okay damn I have to
have anyone else I need to know that I have
done one thing right with my life
do you need anything before I leave
I really just feel like
the full-fledged history of all these characters
you know
I definitely got
temperature just blow snot into my shirt
yeah thanks Dan have a good night okay
dad you're the MVP of this movie does he have
this pizza every night
[Music] damn
right
nice to get a message like that
oh he's really going binging right now it's
like he's trying to end it tonight [Music]
yep your daughter she took these pictures
of me smoking pot and she found my church
in Waterloo somehow and then she sent it to
them and they sent it to my parents and and
you know what they said it's just money and
they want me to come home how awful is that
awful you think Alan died because he chose
to be with me yes wow Alan loved me he thought
it was beautiful halfway through the semester
started meeting me during my office hours
uh-huh it's perfect temperature outside we
took a walk in the Arboretum
tests huh Alan can see what I have done to
myself Carly okay stop this is disgusting
yes I'm disgusting you're disgusting it there
you go you found honestly Thomas it's a really
fascinating examination man I've been replaced
by someone who will no doubt have you rewrite
less authentic less you with every draft
Julian you wrote sick of people telling me
that I have promised
the truth will set you free I just want to
be honest with you too
this course doesn't matter amazing honest
things things they matter
this movie is aggressively sad those last
few months before Alan I'd come over here
Shake him to scream at him just trying to
get him to [__] eat something God that
was awful it was awful for me too yeah well
you weren't the one who had to identify his
body all bloated it wouldn't let me I wasn't
family oh I tried to save him please I thought
that if I just loved him that he wouldn't
need anywhere else me oh nobody could have
saved him believe me I spent years trying
I don't think I believe anyone can save anyone
only you can save yourself she was trying
to help her do you ever get the feeling people
are incapable of not caring he people are
amazing
what the [__] did you do I need to talk
to him
is she actually had to actually expect to
see her again
do you ever get the feeling that people aren't
capable about caring capable of caring I failed
that's a really good essay I don't care that
you're dying do you want me to fail out of
high school is that why you did this I didn't
write it read it read it I wrote this in eighth
grade for English why do you and I feel saddest
of all boring chapters that were only descriptions
of whales oh
the author was just trying to save us from
his own sad stories just for a little while
I wanted to know how you were doing in school
and she sent it and it's the best dancing
I've ever read be like this
I'm sorry for leaving you I was in love and
I left you behind you did not deserve that
I don't I don't know I could have done such
thing you're so beautiful you're amazing stop
ah it's an Essie miss you
you're the best thing I have ever done you're
going to the hospital you just need surgery
or something oh God yeah you [__] kidding
me oh yeah yeah
please oh
I
just named Moby Dick and which is what in
the course of the book the pirate Ahab encounters
many hardships
this is sad because this whale doesn't have
any emotions it doesn't know how bad AF wants
to kill him he's just poor big animal he said
his life will be better if you can just kill
this whale but in reality it won't help him
at all
I
felt saddest of all when I read the boring
chapters that were only descriptions of whales
because I knew that the author was just trying
to save us from his own sad story just for
a little while this book made me think about
my own life and then it made me feel glad
for men
[Music]
that's a [__] Crescendo of an editing
right there oh
wow
I did not put that together that she had rid
of that
I feel like I should have
power it was rare word is so [__] gay
holy God oh man [Music]
I just gotta sit with that for a second
oh
foreign
that was an experience all right I don't think
there's a post credit scene
yeah okay let's talk about it I'll be right
back just gonna blow my nose okie dokie okie
dokie
right [Laughter]
I'm pretty sure
quite a few times on this channel and I'm
pretty sure this is the first time I've seen
a movie where just like that that fight I
don't know I could be blanking on it but like
that final few moments are just like wow this
is like husky
damn uh that was uh that was that was crazy
well all right not really knowing much about
it other than all the talk about Brendan Fraser
is amazing in this film and it's so sad and
I I found the experience interesting because
all right Greg time to focus it's time to
get your thoughts in order after that I found
the experience interesting because you know
I didn't know what I was really walking into
other it's there like someone's saying it's
so sad I'm like well it's Darren Aronofsky
his [__] tends to be pretty sad I really
love like Darren aronofsky's work I think
it's very striking I find Black Swan to be
one of the best horror movies I've ever seen
I even like uh a lot of his most uh divisive
movies I I first joint mother and I I like
I like pretty much most things that I I've
seen from him and I know uh you know Christianity
and inclusion is often a Common Thread and
this was one of those things where it kind
of starts off in a very
melancholic seems like too light of a word
it's harsh it's like a harsh World Of This
Moment In Time uh quite aggressively right
away and normally I haven't seen the fountain
though that popped up on my I still haven't
seen the fountain uh but when when uh when
a movie becomes like so much like that like
you know I liken it to what I call the the
student film syndrome or the short film syndrome
was like look how freaking dramatic we are
look how sad we are to the point where it
becomes ineffective because it just feels
like that's what they're they're going for
but the performances are so strong and it
was the moments it wasn't really like this
stuff when I would like especially when I
get like choked up or cry or something it
wasn't really the stuff where it was just
going you know be sad be sad or something
like that because because it was it was getting
to the it was sometimes linger in in aspects
of that where I found myself kind of thinking
in my head am I gonna end up liking this movie
is this gonna feel monotonous is it gonna
feel I don't know if the right word is pretentious
but is it gonna feel forced right and whenever
it was layered once the movie really started
to click with me I don't exactly know what
point it was but there was a point where I
started to under really feel like I was understanding
who the characters were at least my interpretation
of it you know this is the kind of movie I
imagine there's some really great think pieces
on and dissection of the characters because
there are fully realized characters every
character here is is very much fleshed out
and you really get a sense for their background
and it was stuff where because pain is like
what this whole canvas is painted with the
pain it was Winter honed in on not not like
why the pain is there and you know I thought
I didn't know if it was going to be a movie
about like a movie that's about body dysmorphia
a movie about obesity you know like that's
that's an aspect obviously but it's but it's
like he has become this physical embodiment
uh of of his pain you know that that is what
he represents as as this person as this very
obese struggling person who's like on the
verge of death is accepting the fact that
he's going to die he it's like he shapes himself
into that you know
and I I didn't know if it would just be because
a lot of these characters have these habits
uh of and what I mean by why like why the
pain the specifically the word why why the
pain why that hit me so hard excuse me guys
I'm just coming off a crime session trying
to get my thoughts perfectly aligned here
why that hit me so hard is because you would
see that there was so much love and that love
led to so much hurt and you really got that
sense with this Charlie character especially
him but you could see that with the even with
the the wife and Sadie sink and the Ellie
character you could see that there was probably
a point in time where their Foundation even
before they did the flashbacks on the beach
or whatever there was probably this point
in time where they were really happy you know
and he and he probably did love them but just
didn't love her the wife how you could tell
he still had a love for her but just wasn't
in love with her because he was really gay
and then the path to being in love with this
Allen guy and and what that did for Alan being
part of this church I can imagine this movie
you could offend some people especially with
religious this movie does not do do this is
what I'm gonna do it a little bit later if
there's one criticism I have about the writing
of it it has to do with the real I'm not religious
whatsoever but there is there is a criticism
I have in terms of how the religion aspects
are sort of handled here regardless of what
that feeds into the character of he just wanted
he's like maybe I can save this guy by just
giving him you know uh overwhelming flow of
love and he died and he just blames himself
you know and while these characters often
when [__] gets too hard they will escape
via rather storming out or resorting to anger
he resorts to binge eating you know it is
a form of physically harming yourself and
I've I've never I've been in situations like
that where I just want to eat my pain away
I did that for a very long time and I gained
the like massive amounts of weight and there
would be sessions where like every Saturday
I just end up throwing up just because I would
just eat until I threw up and it it's a sad
way of living in and and I appreciate the
movie portrays it in a way that's not trying
to make it about that but it also is kind
of about that because really it's about who
these people are it's it is it is a human
experience it is a human journey of everyone
here and how yes there's a lot of trauma that
keeps these people bonded together but there's
also it's also rooted in a lot of love and
when you have that quality kind of shine through
because I could see I could see how there
could be a lot of people probably don't like
this movie too because I feel like it could
register as I don't know what the right words
misery porn but I'm gonna go with that I see
I could see how it could register as that
versus like look how artistically depressing
this [__] is nah man when you got that
that's why that Crescendo was so beautiful
to me like God damn that poem he that essay
he keeps reciting uh throughout the whole
film and how you know he's just saying that
he just wants to hear it before he dies and
he's just [__] [__] triple and he
just wants to make his daughter happy that's
all he cares about and that's that's been
consistent with him throughout his whole life
it wasn't like he's been ignoring her he's
wanted to be in contact with her he saved
up all the money like it's it's been a focus
of him of his entire life and it's it's also
a Journey about everyone learning to just
be honest with themselves and being honest
with everyone else you know like that level
of honesty of coming to terms with the truth
EV how do we really feel underneath like it's
a movie about emotions while there's a lot
of dialogue parts that can feel repetitive
and whatnot at the end of the day the the
movie is uh the story is about emotions the
story is about being very honest with it's
kind of like inside out but on a very adult
level it's very it's so much about just okay
yeah you got you you put this on display you
you take out you take you take out all your
pain on your body like this you're a drinker
he's a binge eater he's led to obesity he's
got all these health problems Ellie's doing
everything Ellie does Liz is very Stern and
built up like like she goes into the aggressive
route as well but you got a sense of everyone's
backstory and so over time as you peel back
these layers by the end you just get to everyone's
true emotions and the movie even had me going
with Ellie it honestly reached the point because
at first it wasn't until
it was when she sent the letters the the when
you find it because you're like okay she's
gonna do something with this recording and
stuff is when she sent the recording off to
Thomas's family and you know preceding that
the mom was going uh like she's evil you know
it's like no one to me is born evil it's usually
some form of conditioning right and like I
don't think she was evil what she was doing
but she didn't seem like a great person and
I I did when it reached that point of did
she do that to hurt Thomas or to help Thomas
I was here going
I feel like she might have been trying to
hurt him like that's what the move that's
what I had been sold on where prior to that
prior to the whole like ambient and all that
and and the recording of Thomas I was really
under the impression like you know what yeah
she's she's got a [__] attitude but but
really she loves her dad and like that was
very obvious but I never I didn't really imagine
would get a scene where as I had I had thought
that she wasn't going to come back into the
movie actually I I really thought for some
reason that she just wasn't going to come
back maybe you did and you're smarter than
me whatever I didn't think she was gonna come
back I kind of forgot about it I didn't forget
I just didn't come back so when when she did
come back and then you see like oh the the
essay is what she wrote this beautiful essay
and this is how oh it's so that's so smart
like it makes the whole journey worth it I
I honestly think those last few minutes make
the whole journey worth it and um what was
I talking about sorry what time is it it is
it is literally 12 55 at the four degree out
of watching this movie so
it's just such a red it was such a random
night for me
becoming delusional the uh this stays in the
video me try to remember what I'm talking
about um yeah yeah uh with with aliens everyone's
being honest you find out why everyone is
the way they are I don't remember what I was
exactly talking about whatever this is all
state I don't know I don't care this is gonna
be raw I like the whale's emotions and Sadie's
sink whoa holy everyone can act so well that's
what I was trying to say is that I had the
movie was selling me so much on I actually
don't even know if this is how the girl's
gonna if the movie's gonna end on a note with
uh yeah as you might have just been a [__]
uh but no she like like she was too far gone
from the pain and the trauma she experienced
it was too far gone and there was there's
that she wasn't gonna ever turn to being dabbing
a resolve like Sadie's sink was phenomenal
in this movie is she nominated are the nominations
out I miss I mean yeah I know they are is
Sadie Singh nominated for this film because
she's so good nominated for an Oscar I guess
not damn I mean I don't know who else was
told to do this I'm not gonna be like what
the hell why this person I don't know who
else was nominated she was phenomenal I like
her scenes with Brendan Fraser were so were
so real and believable and layered um talk
about Nuance my God that was so effective
I loved it loved the I loved their dynamic
there were times where there's something about
the Thomas character that's my one criticism
about the movie that just out of all the pieces
for some reason he was the only part that
I wasn't it was the only part of the movie
that I found myself constantly walking a line
with of is this working for me or is this
not working for me and I don't think it there's
a lot of things like that it did Sir for the
the bigger purpose of of the narrative that
undoubtedly yeah and especially with the backstory
with Liz who by the way amazing is is she
a funny woman or something like that is she
like a comedian lady I remember her in the
menu uh and she was excellent in that too
but uh I've never seen her worth to this degree
she was she was phenomenal absolutely phenomenal
what's that actress's name let me find it
for you guys Hong Chow I don't know her work
or maybe I do and I just forget but yeah she's
uh she was excellent uh yeah another beautiful
performer there um because I did the pizza
yeah what would it keep my God okay yeah you
know it's been it's been a little bit of a
13-hour day no no no I know I tend to uh zigzag
in a conversation on these reviews post reaction
but it's especially gonna go down tonight
and I'm keeping it all here um yeah with Thomas
Ty Simpkins while I think the performer Ty
Simpkins did a really good job the while I'm
not a religious person
I did think that there wasn't much given to
this it started to work for me once you find
once you find out what the hell is really
going on with this guy and why he's really
here uh like everything that Ellie ends up
finding out that that's when the it's I was
like okay this is this dramatic shift is actually
making this click for me more it's because
most of his lines pretty much just felt like
America's got totally God put me here for
a reason you got to find God like it just
never got deeper than that and it it didn't
become like it never became thought provoking
anything that he was pitching or saying I
could feel the whoever wrote the because I
imagine that this is a very faithful play
did Samuel D Hunter who wrote this movie also
write the the play I could feel the thought
process of of the the writer uh implementing
his views on religion and you know like I
don't want to offend anyone here I really
really not a fan because I'm I'm the kind
of individual who's like well I'm not real
I grew up Catholic I have a lot of my own
reasons of why I'm not religious now um I
still think that I've I know a good amount
of people who do have faith whether it be
Christian Mormon Catholicism Judaism I know
a good amount of people and if it works for
them and I see that like you know what you're
a good person and uh and I can I can still
be myself around you and I feel like really
comfortable all around you like I I love you
you're great so I don't want a dog uh I don't
want a dog religion Dogma I don't want I don't
want a dog religion um this movie I thought
like yeah you know there are I have no reasons
too for why I'm not a religious person and
I I so I while I don't subscribe to any faith
it did feel like I was hearing a lot of those
The Writer's voice just imposing it and not
really giving any Nuance to uh Thomas's reasoning
for God or belief or or other [__] to
say to char like it never became like a real
debate or conversation about it you know it
just kind of felt like the same repetitive
dialogue then they like assholed himself up
by the end like that that last scene that
he had with him like oh dude dick move I know
he had good intent to put in you know
bad maneuver there so yeah that that was the
one quality of the movie that I I understand
like the purpose it serves thematically for
the characters and and for the movie as a
whole I did think you know even if it is extremely
faithful to the play that it it could have
it could have used some enhancement as opposed
to just the ones who are going to have the
biggest amount of of of uh expansion on reasoning
and debate is going to be all the characters
who are opposed against the religion but the
one who is just keeps showing up to want to
instill the faith is it's never like a compelling
argument like I know this is that it's not
a Netflix this is not a Netflix series it's
a movie but I think a great example of one
that does it is um midnight mass Mike Flanagan
show the the priest on that show like when
he does a sermon uh I don't remember what
episode it was but I was like you know what
I follow this guy I become religious I was
in the room screw it I'm cool I'm going full
Catholic right now and not that it needed
to reach that level I just think you could
have used a little bit of peppering of that
is all I'm getting and then I think I I would
have just been fully immersed in it but yeah
no this was a miserable experience in a lot
of ways but what are those one of those that
I was I was just full I I did I did get lost
in and you know it's it as much as uh in the
beginning it was like this definitely feels
like a play uh it began to really evolve into
feel like a film like and I mean I mean that
in a really complimentary way like there are
certain movies I watch where I just feel like
I was watching a play and and sometimes it's
not complementary like sometimes you gotta
you gotta fuse the worlds I think when you
translate uh play to film like like Glenn
Ross is an amazing job at that from as being
a film uh fences while beautifully acted I
really felt like I was just watching a stage
flame they were cutting back between the same
three shots where here you still have a nice
great use of cinematography um atmosphere
you could feel the isolation yet you get a
sense of like just beyond the door is the
outside world where he's never gonna go to
eeo what's the wildlife Erin obstacle bringing
some of his visual like I felt like the ending
especially with him like raising up you know
dying with acceptance and peace and happiness
getting that relief that felt very aronofsky-like
and even the use of the flashback uh on the
on the beach felt very aeronofsky so having
some of those like film language visual flourishes
I thought was great I thought there was amazing
music in here uh the Liz character I really
like the dynamic between them because you
don't really see a dynamic like that in film
and uh I thought that her
she just feels like people I've met like she
really does she really feels like people I've
met where it was also cool about her it's
nice to get like an I don't think they did
they don't ever make mention of the fact that
she is actually Asian huh as a Filipino it
makes me happy to see her in fact that she's
a nurse I think she's a nurse I might just
protect you um but the fact that she's Asian
and they don't make it a thing that she's
Asian I'm pretty sure they don't they're more
kudos to that but the dynamic of you were
the best thing that happened to my brother
and I loved you for who you were when my brother
was around and now I must protect you too
and look after you as well it's a very fascinating
Dynamic and again you could really feel you
could feel like these actors all fleshed out
the history that's like that's what you want
from these performances is you don't need
to say much but whenever you guys are talking
like I can tell that all you guys know all
the memories more than what's being said on
screen or even into that like you guys really
know your memories
and yeah I haven't really touched much on
him Brendan Fraser I saved it for the end
when most people have already clicked off
this video Brendan Fraser is
peace Beyond exceptional he's astronomical
in this film I thought I'd be watching a movie
where I just kept going Brendan Fraser doing
great you know where I'm just aware I'm watching
Brendan Fraser the whole time and like look
at Brendan Fraser acting he became this guy
hands down the best performance he's ever
done hands down he was just this dude you
know and he he wasn't like ever it's like
a heavy per no but it said it's like a heavy
performance it is and what I respected so
much about it was it did feel like I was looking
at someone's life on screen because I'm not
even talking about how it correlates with
Brendan Fraser the actor or something like
that I I'm talking about how you know they
had that thing in there where he tries to
be optimistic and he tries to find the positive
spin when clearly this guy is in a world of
his own misery and it's just utterly depressed
he he carried this it felt authentic just
so the word that comes to mind is sincerity
it's it's genuine that that uh that tenderness
towards others that that interesting care
and and and the power of the language and
the and embracing the honesty and like the
love that he has you can really feel it just
embroiled in so much so much shame and lack
of self-worth there's like no self like so
much love exerted but no but no self-love
you know like even when he talks about Alan
and Thomas or he's getting defensive he's
like I was never remember the best looking
guy in the room but he thought I was beautiful
like even then before he even became this
like shape that he becomes even then you get
the idea that this guy never never really
had self-love did he as much as he could find
it elsewhere as much as you can find love
he never had it for himself it was such a
fully realized performance it was painstakingly
beautiful who's he up against I want to know
who's up against
yeah oh boy you deserve some awards um Oscar
nominations 2033 oh you're going up against
Austin Butler
you did become Elvis for like five years
foreign
Fraser still deserves it I've seen both of
these movies and uh
yeah I think Brandon Frazier deserves it
I'm saying that right now [Laughter]
anyway guys
awesome Butler will get another chance the
guy's like five years old he go get another
chance let Brendan Fraser have it
and Austin Butler can go up on stage and slap
him ladies and gentlemen what did you think
of the whale did you enjoy it I guess I'd
give it like a 8 out of ten yeah yeah I'm
confident with that like an eight out of 10.
alrighty well I had to jump like an 8.5 like
the acting it's just two two two two minutes
not my favorite Airline like not by not by
a long shot but uh it's it's still it's it
is very moving and that ending that ending
like really made the whole thing
like really sing for me oh the person plays
wife also incredible incredible she has like
one scene in this movie like she showed up
he she did her homework she was great and
that again I appreciate the I appreciate how
it's not just people screaming at each other
that they would you could see that it was
all at the end of the day all whatever anger
frustrations there's always rooted in
in love anyway reject Nation
dig deeper in your emotions and and if you're
in pain or you find yourself in a stress or
angry State sometimes I gotta do that sometimes
I'm like just kind of like I do these exercises
because I can be a very emotional guy I do
these exercises where I close my eyes and
I'll just start saying how I feel like just
very subconscious very stream of Consciousness
and I'll just find my face doing this
why do I feel angry angry is usually a sign
that I'm hurt am I feeling hurt by something
what am I hurt by like I gotta like dissect
it a little bit so I encourage the same thing
too alrighty I'm gonna try to edit this other
movie reaction first to round to it but thank
you for being here